a better way to manage your passwords
and to protect your personal information
rich demuro explains in today's tech
smart
[Music]
we're always hearing stories about how
the most popular passwords are also the
easiest to crack
it's time to step up your personal
security and start using
a password manager
let's face it reusing the same password
over and over puts your personal data
at serious risk which is why you need to
use a password manager you can make a
password that's 60
characters 128 128 that's pretty secure
michael crandall is ceo of bit warden
makers of popular password management
software that also happens to be free
part of our key part of our philosophy
is that basic password management
should be free for everyone good to know
at a time when many users are looking
for a new option after another popular
app called lastpass
announced it's now charging for features
that used to be free
one key aspect of the password manager
is that it be available for you
on every device and every platform that
you use
password managers work by generating
strong unique
and random passwords for the sites you
visit when you go back to log in
the app remembers the password and even
fills it in bit warden as a company
as a service can never ever see your
passwords
they're only available to you other free
options include
dashlane google's password manager built
into android and chrome
and apple's icloud keychain but those
can be more limited
no matter which password manager you
choose it's a step in the right
direction
do you believe that this is truly a more
secure way of managing
a personal online identity than just
using the same password over and over
it is in a different galaxy rich
of security i'm really impressed with
the features that bit warden offers for
free
and if you decide to step up to a paid
plan it's just ten dollars a year
you can learn more about all of these
password manager options on my website
just go to rich on tech dot tv i'm rich
demero and you
are tech smart